émile-nelligan un génie précoce dont les
verts ont profondément marqué l'histoire
de la poésie au québec même si sa
carrière a été de courte durée
on ne venez-vous de 16 heures jusqu'à 19
heures il écrit tout dans ces trois
années notre un beau c'est un vrai beau
[Musique]
son destin tragique est racontée dans un
opéra présenté sur les planches du tnm
une oeuvre créée il ya 30 ans toute la
musique est un foie gras flash back dans
sa vie de jeunesse y revoit sa famille
ses amis des moments marquants de sa vie
créatrice nehlig ans est né à montréal
en 1879 dans une famille bourgeoise de
père d'origine irlandaise et d'une mère
francophone ce cette femme et l'homme -
je m'intéressais le conflit entre le
père et la mère de conflit un peu
évident et son père et sa mère de
l'adolescence il se passionne pour la
poésie et publie des oeuvres résolument
moderne
c'est paul poèmes pas de la ruralité y
en avait à cette époque louis fréchette
avait touché ces choses de loups ou de
l'histoire des anciens canadiens
non c'est un nouvel être une nouvelle
poésie qui va naître et c'est ça qui est
formidable c'est sa mère qui lui a donné
en fait tout l'amour qu'il a pour les
mots pour la musique pour l'art et ça
vient de sa mère et je crois que sans sa
sensibilité aussi exacerbé de nébian ça
vient aussi du personnage la mer d'où la
grande tragédie pour emilie qui doit
constater que chi chi et la santé
mentale fragile
un peu avant son 20e anniversaire son
état de santé mentale se dégrade et sa
famille décide de le faire est ternie de
nos jours il y aurait pas fini enfermé
dans une autre salle après qu'on leur
ait soigner entre tout chaud il y aurait
continué à créer puis avait continué à
avoir ces images qui sait sa folie pts
ce prix on aurait fait 3 auquel beaucoup
[Musique]
un siècle plus tard les mots de nelly
gants continue de résonner avec force et
beauté du synavi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal
[Musique]